[موسيقى]
طبتم وطابت اوقاتكم لم تحسب النتيجه حتى
الان هذه الساعه الاخباريه من العربيه
لمتابعه نتائج الانتخابات النصفيه ما
ظهر الان من هذه النتائج يبينوا ان
التنافس حاد للغايه بين الحزبين فلا سيطر
كامله حتى هذه اللحظه اهم ما كشفت عنه
النتائج هو منصب مقعد شيوخ في ولايه
بنسلفانيا الذي فاز به المرشح الديمقراطي
جون فترمان على الجمهوري محمد اوس هذا
المقعد كان يشغله سيناتور جمهوري متقاعد
بالتالي
مهم من يد الجمهوريه لكن حتى الان
لم يتم حسمها لاين من الحسبين في يسيطر
الجمهوريون على 48 مقها ويسيطر
الديمقراطيون على مثلهم قد تنتهي
الانتخابات في النهايه باعاده الوضع لما
كان عليه قبل هذه الانتخابات الولايات
المتبقيه حتى الان في مجلس الشيوخ والتي
لم يتم اعلان نتائجها هي جورجيا اريزونا
ويسكنسن ونيفادا ما تنبئ به التوقعات حتى
الان ان الجمهوريين سيفوزون بمقعد ويسكن
صن الذي يتنافس فيه السيناتون جونسون مع
الديمقراطيين مانديس وفي ارينا اقرب الظن
ان السيناتور الديمقراطيه ماركلي سيفوز
على المرشح المدعوم من ترامب لك مع
السلامه
قانونيه محتدمه بعد الانتخابات وذلك
لاغلاق لجان انتخابيه اغلاق ابوابها يوم
الاقتراع بسبب المشاكل القانونيه ينحصر
اذا الصراع الذي همم سيحسم مجلس الشيوخ
ولايتين هما جورجيا وكذلك في طبعا في
الجنوب الشرقي وكذلك نيفادا في الغرب
الامريكي حتى الان يتقدم في جورجيا
سيناتور الحالي رافاييل على المرشح
المدعوم من الترام الشروق
لكن لا نتائج نهائيا نكرر الا النتائج
نهائيا نيفادا يامر هناك الجمهوريون ان
ينتزعوها من يد الديمقراطيين كما انتزع
الحزب الازرق من سلفانيا
لكن بعد نحو الثمانين في المئه من الاصوات
يتقدم المرشح الجمهوري ادم حتى الان
بنقطتين مئويهتين يمكن ان نقول ان مجلس
الشيوخ في اغلب الظل ذهب الى تقسيم
المقاعد تساوي بين الحزبين اي العوده الى
المربع الاول قبل الانتخابات لك نعود
ونؤكد مجددا هذه مجرد توقعها
[موسيقى]
كان ذلك في مجلس الشيوخ لكن
الخجوله على مجلس النواب دخلت خانه الخطر
مع ظهور نتائج بشكل تدريجي النتائج
الاوليه للانتخابات التجديد النصفيه تظهر
تقدم الجمهوريين ب 27 متعدا حتى هذه
اللحظه مع نيلهم 199 المقعدا مقابل مئه
واثنين
وسبعين
الديمقراطيين
وفقها فقط
[موسيقى]
مقعدا مقابله 180
متعدا للج الجمهوريه اذا نتائج تتباين بعض
الدوائر المتارجحه بين ولايات امريكيه
مختلفه فقط تحدد هويه الحزب الذي سيهيمن
على المجلس لسنتين مقبلاتين اي حصول
الجمهوريين على الاغلبيه او تعزيز
الاغلبيه الضيئيله للديمقراطيين ما قبل
هذه الانتخابات يحتاج الجمهوريون هنا الى
مكاسب صافيه قدرها خمسه مقاعد في مجلس
النواب لتحقيق اغلبيه
218 مقعدا السؤال هنا
ماذا لو فاز الجمهوريون بانتخابات مجلس
النواب ماذا يعني ذلك قد يمهد هذا الفوز
المامول الطريق للنائب الجمهوري كيف
المكان لسحب المطرقه من يد رئيس مجلس
النواب الديمقراطيه نانسي
والحلول مكانها والجلوس مكانها كما ستكون
العتر الاساسيه في طريق بايدين وقد تعيق
تمثيل اجنده التشريعيه مع وعود الجمهوريين
بانهاء خططه لاكثر طبعا الاكثر طموحا
البعض يقول انه ربما مشى في ذلك على
الطريقه التشريعي لكن البعض الاخر قد يشكل
نجاح الجمهوريين عائقا بالنسبه له عموما
التوقعات تخرج هنا بامكانيه استخدام
الفيتو هذا السلاح الذي لم يكن بحاجه
لاستخدامه عن خلافه ميزه السيطره
الديمقراطيه على الكونجرس ولكن في العامين
السابقين
طيب
من مدينه هاريسبورغ بولايه بنسلفانيا ينضم
الينا مراسل العربيه بكير غانم اهلا بك بك
لربما نتحدث عن بن سلمان اولا ما الذي حدث
كيف حدث هذا الفوز وهل بالتالي حسن الامر
هناك نهائيا على الاقل دعنا في اجواء
تفاصيل ما حدث يعني يوم امس وصباح اليوم
انتصر على منافسه الجمهوري محمد
هذا النجاح يعتبره الديمقراطيون انتصار
كبير بالنسبه لهم اولا لان فطر من الذي
كان يتنافس بشكل شديد مع منافسه الجمهوري
تقدم عليه بشكل مريح وتبين ان هذه الاصوات
تعطيه هذا المنصف في مجلس الشيوخ لماذا
هذا الموضوع مهم مهم لانك كما ذكرت عنده
قبل قليل عادل اخذ هذا المقعد لصالح
الديمقراطيين من مقعد جمهوري وبالتالي هذا
التحول يضع الجمهوريين في وضع الصعب لو
صحه التعبير في ان ينالوا مجلس الشيوخ نحن
نتقدم باتجاه ان لدينا مجلس الشيوخ 50 50
ويبقى في يده
الرئيس هي الرئيس مجلس الشيوخ وتعطيه ملك
فريق طيب الامريكي كيف يقراون هذا الفوز
وفوز منطقي وعقلالاني ام هو عاطفي اكثر
تعاقفهم مع فترمان وبالتالي خساره اوز
لهذا المقعد
نبدا اولا بالقول عادل ان النظر الاساسيه
كانت تقول ان هناك اكتساح جمهوري لهذه
الانتخابات الاسابيع الاخيره لم تكن كذلك
وبالتالي تحولت الانتخابات اكثر من انها
حزبيه على مستوى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الى محليه على مستوى الولايه او
على مستوى الدائره الانتخابيه بالنسبه
لمجلس النواب الان ما لدينا هو صور
الديمقراطيون محمد اوز على انه صنيعه
ترامب على انه غريب من خارج الولايه دخل
الى هذه الولايه فقط ل- يقتصر فرصه سياسيه
وهم نجحوا الى حد ما في تصويره على انه
كذلك في المقابل لم يتمكن الجمهوريون من
القول ان جون فترمن الذي اصيب بجلطه
دماغيه غير مؤهل لهذا المنصب في سلفانيا
بالاضافه الى هذا وذاك اضافت عدد جيد من
الاصوات الديمقراطيه خلال السنتين
الماضيتين وتمكن الرئيس بايدن بمساعده
ايضا الرئيس السابق باراك اوباما من اخراج
المصوتين الافارقه السود خصوصا في منطقه
فيلادلفيا وبيتسبرغ الى صناديق الاقتراع
وصوتوا لفترمن وضمان لنفسهم هذا المقعد
على حساب الجمهوريه
ايضا انت من خلال متابعتك بن سلفانيا اين
حدثت نقطه التحول في هذه الانتخابات
واتحدث عن عمليات الفرز فرز الاصوات هل
بسبب دفع الديمقراطيين لانصارهم للتصويت
المبكر امام ماذا
اعتقد ان خلال الساعات التي سبقت بدء
التصويت الشخصي كانت هناك مساء واضحه من
قبل ان الديمقراطيين من المنظمات التابعه
لهم التي تدعو الناس الى التصويت بشكل
شخصي وهم نجحوا بذلك لان لديهم اجهزه
متطوره تعمل على الارض الاتصال بالناخبين
وهم لو نظرنا الى خريطه الانتخابات بنسبه
لجون فاترمان فهو قبل الفعل همم فاز
باكثريه عاليه من الاصوات في المدن فيها
في بيسبر في منطقه هاريس بورك وبالتالي
همم الخريطه كانت واضحه سكان المدن صوتوا
لي ديمقراطيين وسكان همم خارج المدن
المزارع صوته للجمهوريه طيب اذا ما اردنا
هذه طبعا بنسبه لك ليست هو الانتخابات
النصفيه حتى الرئاسيه كير لكن اريد هنا
قراءتك بخبرتك كيف ننظر الان الى بس
الشيوخ كيف ننظر الى مجلس النواب الى اين
تتجه البوصله على الاقل بقراءه اوليه
اعتقد ان القراءه الاهم التي يجب ان نحتفظ
بها هو اننا نذهب الى سنتين من الحياه
السياسيه الصاخبه في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لا اقول صعبه اقول ساقبه لدينا
اولا الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب ولديه
اشخاص دخلوا الى الكونجرس الامريكي
وهمدينوننا دونالد ترامب في دخولهم الى
الكونغرس هناك مجموعه اخرى من الجمهوريين
الذين لا يحبذونا دونالد ترامب ويريدون
الابتعاد عنهم هناك صف واحد من
الديمقراطيين ولكنهم لا يتمتعون باغلبيه
كبيره في صفوف الكونجرس ربما ينقسم
الكونجرس الامريكي مجلس الشيوخ الديمقراطي
مجلس النواب جمهوري ويضطر
يتفاوضها مع نفسه
ويجد همم
زعيم همم الديمقراطيين في مجلس الشيوخ
يتفاوض مع كارثي زعيم محتمل لمجلس النواب
ويضطر ايضا الرئيس بايدن ليتفاوض معها
مجلس الشيوخ ومجلس النواب حول اما يريدونه
وما يريد الرئيس ان يمرره او ينجزه من
انجازات سنكون في مرحله صاخبه ولكنها لم
تكون مرحله صعبه طيب اشرح لي ذلك ايضا انه
يعني قبيله همم يعني مع فتح صناديق
الاقتراع كان هناك ربما افتتاح همم سوق
همم الاوراق الماليه او حتى همم بعض همم
البورصه كانت هناك ارتفاع ومؤشرات تنظر او
تقول بان جمهوريون قادمون كان هناك دعايه
اكبر من انه الاحمر سيجسس هذا اللون همم
سيكتسح الولايات ما الذي حدث رغم ضعف
الديمقراطيين خلال هذه الانتخابات هناك
صوت كان يقول بان الجمهوريين اضعف من
الديمقراطيين في هذه الانتخابات هل
الامريكيون يقراون ذلك بالفعل
نبدا اولا
بسوء القراءه القراءه كانت صحيحه في
الربيع الماضي لقد شاهدنا تضخما شاهدنا
غلاءا شاهدنا تململا كبيرا في صفوف
الامريكيين
وشاهدنا ايضا ارتفاع حظوظ الجمهوريين في
الانتخابات ولكن الانتخابات كانت على
مسافه سبعه اشهر خلال هذه الاشهر السبعه
ما حصل هو ان الحكومه الامريكيه بيزعامه
بايضه عملت بشكل جاد على مكافحه التضخم
والغلاء وهي نجحت الى حد ما في تخفيف هذه
الحمله وهذا الحمل عن الامريكيين في
المقابل صار شيء لم يكن في يد الجمهوريين
وهو قرار المحكمه العليا بالغاء القرار
القديم الذي همم عمليه يعتبر ان الاجهاض
هو حق الدستوري للنساء في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هذا حول جزء كبير من
همم الناخبين الامريكيين خصوصا النسوان من
تاييد الجمهوريين بسبب الغلاء الى تاييد
الديمقراطيين بسبب قضيه حقوق النساء
وبالتالي الامور تغيرت كثيرا خلال المرحله
الماضيه من اخطا اخطا انه اعتبر اننا في
يوم الانتخابات ومازلنا في الربيع الماضي
ولكن هناك اشياء كثيره وباء كثير عبر تحت
الجسر منذ ذلك الحين في الغانم شكرا جزيلا
لك على كل هذه المعلومات وهذه القراءه من
نهار سبورت بولايه من سلفانيا مراسل
العربيه في الغانم جزيل الشكر
طيب كان هذا الوضع في بنسلفانيا في جورجيا
يتواصل الفرز كما شرحنا لحسم مقعد الشيوخ
بين الديمقراطيه رافاييلا وارنكو
والجمهوري هيرش وبوكر هذه بعض اراء
الديمقراطيين حول عمليه الانتخابيه نقراها
ونشاهدها معا
نا
لذلك كان الامر مفاجئا يتوقع انه كان في
الصداره لكن لم يكن هيرش القريبا من هذا
الحد اعتقد انه اذا فقدنا مجلس الشيوخ
وخسرنا في خذوني عامين فلن نكون نموذجيه
لبقيه العالم
من جورجيا معانا هناك هاتفيه حسين الطود
مراسل العربيه حسين يبدو ان الفرز الى
الان محتدم والصراع بين الاثنين قريب جدا
ماذا يحدث
جورج
[موسيقى]
تقريبا 96% من الاصوات الفارق بينهما همم
0.5 هي هو فارق بسيط همم المهم في هذه
العدد وفي هذه النسبه انه اذا لم يحصل اي
منهما على 50% نحن نتجه الى دوله
كما حصل عام 2020 هو تكرار السيناريو
الماضي همم طبعا الديمقراطيون همم يقولون
انه سيكون ذلك لصالح
مرشحهم رفاييل نار لاسباب عديده منها
الحاكم ابراهيم كم لن يكون على ورقه
الاختراع وهو الذي ساعد الحد كبير وفقهم
همم واقر بالحصول على هذه الاصوات همم
ولكن التاريخ الاعاده في جورجيا عام 1960
الى اليوم في الحقيقه هو لصالح الجمهوريين
من اصل 11 جوله اعاده افادتها سبع مرات
الجمهوريون همم
حسين اذا ما اتجهنا الى جوله اعاده
طبعا يجب
ان
جورج هي من الولايات التي القويه
الجمهوريه لكن في سنوات
[موسيقى]
الناخبين الامريكيين من اصول افريقيه
لانهاء سنوات وعقود من المشاركه السلبيه
والادلاء باصواتهم وقد ايه
فلذلك في نتائج الانتخابات الماضيه عندما
ساهموا بفوز ورناق وجان اوصاف
الديمقراطيين وقلب الولايه من اللون
الاحمر الى اللون الازرق وايضا ساهموا
بفوز جوبايدن في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
الظروف ليست كما كان عليه من قبل قبل عشر
سنوات ولكن التاريخ ما زال كذا نتكلمنا
بلغه الارقام التاريخ الى لصالح
الجمهوريين ولكن الواقع الحالي قد يكون
مختلفا كما قلنا طبعا همم واقرر في
الحقيقه
الجميع كما سمعنا بسبب هذا التقدم الذي
حققه مؤخرا ووقف كان دائما خلال همم
الاشهر الماضيه
غرناك بحسب استطلاعات الراي ولكن منذ
بدانا نلاحظ انه منذ بدايه شهر نوفمبر
اقترب ووقر من قبل وتخطاه كانت استطلاعات
الرئيسيه تعطيها الافضل ليا همم في همم
هذا همم هذه الانتخابات الان هذا ما نراهم
اليوم
الماضيه كانت نتائج همم تتارجح بينه وبين
غرناف يعني فاتنافس على شده بين الاثنين
بهذا الاتجاه يعني
كقراءات الاستطلاع
التي
[موسيقى]
جدا عادل وكما قلت المشكله صحه تعبير بانه
اذا لم يحصل اي منهما
على همم 50% من الاصوات احنا لايبونه
اعاده والسبب في ذلك في الحقيقه هو موجود
مرشح ثالث هو تشيس اوليفر عن الحزب
البريطاني الذي ياخذ اصوات من هذا ومن ذلك
احط اثنين% من الاصوات هو ياخذها ما يحرم
اي منهما من الحصول على 50% اذا طبعا اذا
فاز وهوكر
هذه وهذا ما كان يعني يحسبونه الجمهوريون
المعركه الانتخابيه لصالحهم هناك ستكون
المفاجاه وستكون وسيكون همم كما كان
متوقعا انه الفائز مجلس الشيوخ عن ولايه
جورجيا سيحدد الحلم الذي سيطر على مجلس
الشيوخ لعام
مراسل العربيه من جورجيا شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
زعيم الجمهوريين اكد بمجلس النواب كيف
المكان في اكدال جمهورينا سيستعدون او
سيستعدون كذلك السيطره على مجلس النواب
مشيرا الى ان الجمهوريين عملوا طيله
العامين الماضيين على تلبيه طموحات
الامريكيين وكانت النتيجه دعم الملايين من
جميع انحاء البلاد لهم
[تصفيق]
وين بالضبط
[موسيقى]
من جهتها قالت رئيسه مجلس النواب الامريكي
ان المرشحين من الحزب الديمقراطيه فاقو
التوقعات بقوه في الانتخابات النصفيه
واضافه انها تتوقع تحقيق المزيد من
المكاسب مع احتساب جميع الاصوات
في مجلس النواب الامريكي عن ولايه
كاليفورنيا بنحو
82% من الاصوات وذلك للدوره التاسعه عشره
على التوالي
هذه التغطيه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
ترامب يحذروا حاكم فلوريدا الجمهوريه من
منافسته في انتخابات 2024 ويهدده بكشف
ملفات محرجه
[موسيقى]
بين اليوم بعيد
حياتي
بملى الصفحه
[موسيقى]
نختار
اكثر من 40 قناه اعلاميه تحتضنها العاصمه
السعوديه الرياض ضمن فعاليات المهرجان
العربي للاذاعه والتلفزيون 2022 تحت شعار
الاعلام في عالم يتشكل نخبه الاعلام
في الحدث الذي تنظمه هيئه الاذاعه
والتلفزيون خلال الفتره من التاسع الى
الثاني عشر نوفمبر في فندق هيلتون الرياض
[موسيقى]
الشريك الاعلامي العربيه
حياكم الله على الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب جمهورينا يتفوقون في عدد من
الولايات بفورقه جيده عن الديمقراطيين وهم
يبلون جيدا في انتخابات التجديد النصفي
حتى اللحظه
ايلون
خسارتنا في انتخابات التجديد وهذا قد يكون
مستبعدا الجمهوريون يتفوقون في عدد من
الولايات بفوارق جيده ونحن نبلي جيدا في
الانتخابات حتى اللحظه ونتوقع نتائج رائعه
للجمهوريين في الانتخابات النصفيه
المنافسه وكاله محتدمه في ولايه
بعض وسائل الاعلام الحاضره شككت بقدره
الجمهوريين على الفوز
اكدت وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه فوزا حاكم
فلوريدا الجمهوريه روندي سانتوس بولايه
جديده وهو يعد مرشحا محتملا للرئاسه في
العام 2014 اشارت وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه
الى فوز دي سانتوس على منافسه
الديمقراطيات تشارلي كريست ليستمر في
منصبه حاكما لولايه فلوريدا لولايه ثانيه
ما يعزز من صعوده بشكل بارز في الحزب
الجمهوري مع طموحات محتمله بالوصول الى
البيت الابيض
الى ذلك حظر ترامب حاكمه فلوريدارون
ديسانتس من منافسته على الترشيح الحزب
الجمهوريه للرئاسه في عام 2024 ترامب قال
في لقاء مع فوكس نيوز انه يعرف نيسان 9
اشياء اكثر من اي شخص حتى من زوجته على حد
قوله
وسطها نجمه دي سانتوس في اوساط اليمين
السياسي المحافظ في الاونه الاخيره حتى
بات ينظر اليه كمنافس جدا محتمل لترامب
من جد ينضم الينا الباحث في العلاقات
الدوليه الدكتور بندر الدوشي حياك الله
دكتور يعني اليوم حينما نتحدث عن هذه
النتائج الاوليه حتى الان هل نحن نتحدث عن
ضعف ديمقراطي ام تكتيك انتخابي جيد لهم هل
نحن نتحدث عن اختلاف وجوهات النظر في
الحزب الجمهوري هي ما اضعفت الحزب بعد ان
كنا نتحدث عن اكتساحا احمر للولايات
الامريكيه
اهلا وسهلا حياكم الله اولا ال ال كل
العوامل اللي ظهرت الان والنتائج اللي
ظهرت الان
بحسب المراقبين كانت غير متوقعه بالنسبه
لحزب الجمهوري يعني الان حينما نتابع حتى
لو انتصر الحزب الجمهوريه واخذ مجلس
النواب وهو مرجح لكن الكونجرس الامريكي
وهو خساره بنسلفانيا كانت عاصمه للدار
خساره مقعده الان الجمهوريه يخسرون مقعد
في ظل اوضاع كانت امواتيه للحزب الجمهوري
بالتقدم والسيطر على كل المجلسين نظرا
للتضخم وارتفاع الجريمه هذه العوامل يعني
بعد سنتين ما راح نقدر نشوفها يعني ممكن
تختفي ويكون الحزب الجمهور في موقف اضعف
مما هو الان الان حسب الجمهوري كان لديه
القوه
والدوافع والبيئه السياسيه في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه يعني ن- نتذكر في عام
الديمقراطيون على مجلس النواب
واحتفلوا احت كبيرا كانت هذه الفتره
الاقتصاد الامريكي قوي الوظائف الامريكيه
مرتفعه انخفاض المستوى الجريمه البيئه
السياسيه مواهه الحسبه الجمهوريين ومع ذلك
همم اخذوا مجلس النواب بالتالي حتى لو
اعلنت الجمهوريون ان ااه السيطره على مجلس
النواب الجمهور الامريكي هو بمثابه انتصار
هو بمثابه انتصار ولكن ليس الانتصار الذي
كان يطمح اليه في ظل الظروف التي يعاني
منها الحزب الديمقراطي وخصوصا همم ضعف
معدلات تاييد ارتفاع مستوى الجريمه فتح
الحدود الجنوبيه همم للمهاجرين والغير همم
المجرمين همم
ارتفاعات تبخهم ال- ال- العوامل السياسيه
الخارجيه الحرب الروسيه همم هناك ناس يعني
معاندون
للمساعدات الامريكيه الاوكرانيا بشكل
مستمر هذه العوامل كانت اقوى فرصه ثانيه
يعني يستطيع الجمهوريه
لماذا لم يكتسح الجمهوريون هل سوء اختيار
لعناصر همم
هذه الانتخابات ام انه لم يستطيعوا ان
يدفعوا انصارهم همم الذهاب الى صناديق
الاقتراع كما حدث مع الديمقراطين انا
اعتقد ان المساله يعني لو نرجع للتصريحات
مثل مكان رئيس زعيم الاغلبيه جمهور حينما
يعني توقع الا يسيطر الجمهوريون على على
مجلس الشيوخ وكان يرى جوده المرشحين هي
السبب يعني اعتقد ان زوجته المرشحين في
ابن سلمان
وخارج الولايه
وبايد همم ترامب بانتخابات النصفيه عام
2020 كانت مزوره ووقف على رايه رغم ان
الكثير كان يحدرون من هذه الاراء ايضا ال-
ال- الشباب قضيه همم الجيل الجديد قضيه
همم
اللي هو قضيه الاجهاض والغاء قضيه الاجهاض
ايضا قضيه هناك مستقلون كانت هذه
الامريكيه الحزب الجمهوري لا يحبون ترامب
نيفر ترامب مجموعه نيفار ترامب هؤلاء لم
يصوتوا للجمهوريون المستقلون ايضا هم من
يرجح
كفه الديمقراطيه او الجمهور المستقلون
هناك الباب بانهم صوت الكف
اف تقول ما حدث هو نجاح لم يحدث منذ 20
عاما بالنسبه للديموقراطين هذه العوامل
هذه المؤثرات هناك خشيه من عوده الترام
هناك المستقلون يخشون من عوده الترام
للمستقبل
بمستقبلا وبالتالي هذه رساله كبيره للرئيس
الامريكي دون ترامب ورساله واضحه وصاحبه
للرئيس الجمهوريه السابق بانه
في الانتخابات القادمه
الرجل الرجل قد يعلنها يوم خمسه 15
نوفمبر وبالتالي هو حتى ايضا حاكم بيقول
هذه فلوريدا فبالتالي هو ما ظن في طريقه
لرئاسه جديده
انا اعتقد انه سوف يعمل سوف يعلن ترشح
للرئاسه ولكن لديه شقوق عميق جدا من انه
سوف ينتصر في عام 2024 نظرا لنتائج اليوم
نظرا نتائج انتخابات النصفيه لو حدثت موجه
حمراء في مجلس الشيوخ وسيطروا على اربعه
مقاعد كما كان المتوقعا او باغلبيه اربع
مقاعد او سيطروا على مجلس النواب و مجلس
بشكل كامل كانت الارقام كلها ستدفع بان
ترامب سوف يعود السلطه عام 2024 لكن مع
هذه الارقام مع هذه النتائج المخيفه التي
وصفها بعض المرافقين بانها كانت يعني كانت
هي بالنسبه للجمهوريه ويسيطر على النبي
الا انها لم تكون المنطقه الان خسروا مقعد
جمهوري في بنسلفانيا وتوقع انهم يخسروا
يعني الحبوب متقاربه في جورجيا نيفاده من
الممكن ان تتحول نيفادا الى اللون الاحمر
ولكن بس خساره بنسلفانيا قد يكون التعادل
50 50
في عام 1420 بعد هذا الانتخابات ستكون اقل
من المتوسط لن نقول عاليه ولكن متوسطه او
ضعيفه بان يفوز بالسلطه ممكن يعني اذا
نظرنا الى ديسانتوس اعتقد ان حدودها واقوى
بكثير طيب نظرا اول ادي سانتوس هو همم
شخصيه محفظه لديه دعم لاتينيين وهي يعني
تشكل 30% من مجموعه من
الناخبين لك ايه فاذا يعني بيسان سوف يشكل
قيمه كبيره للحزب الجمهوري في عام 2024
وبالتالي اعتقد انه سيستطيع الاتصال على
بيض بسهوله اذا همم دعمه الرئيس الامريكي
دونالد ترامب خلينا نذهب الى الى
بعيد
نفسه حينما قال من ان اذا ما فاز
الجمهوريون ستكون واشنطن صعبه عليها اول
الحياه في واشنطن همم صعب لكن وفق هذه
النتائج حتى الان هل ترى ان مهمه بعيدا
خلال العامين القادمين همم ستكون سهله
نوعا ما قد يمرر المشاريع التي يريدها
وبالتالي يصل الى الولايه الثانيه
من عدلي اكثر من من اي موضوع اخر هو يخشى
من عزله فاذا سيطر على مجلس النواب فشروا
في السيطره على كونغرس سوف يستطيع التفاوض
هو رجل مفاوض من الثمانينات كان شخص قوي
جدا ويستطيع لديه علاقه جديده مع زعيم
الاقليه في مجلس الشيوخ
تمرير مشاريع بقدرته على التفاوض مع
الجمهوريين ومع المستقلين ومع حتى
الديمقراطين اليسا
التشريعي في مايكل كونغرس الامريكي والديه
القدره على تمرين المشاري لكن كل ما يخشاه
هو عزله او فتح تحقيقات كبيره بسبب
الاسعاف في افغانستان بسبب قضايا همم
استاذه الديون اللي همم
للقروض الطلاب وهي في الحقيقه اثرت كثيرا
في خروج الناخبين لدعمه في همم حتى ان بعض
الجمهور الا هذه يتهمون ان همم بانها رشوه
قضيه سداد
ومساعده الديمقراطين على تحديد او تقليل
الموجه الحمراء نعم شكرا جزيلا اللي همم
الباحث في العلاقات الدوليه الدكتور بندر
الدوشي كنت معنا من جده يعطيك العافيه
فازت المتحدث السابقه بس مادونالد ترامب
في البيت الابيض ساره ساندرياس بمنصبي
حاكم ولايه اركانساس لتصبح اول امراه تقود
الولايه واعلى مسؤول في اداره ترامب في
منصب منتخب
وهزمت ساندرياس المرشحه الديمقراطي كريس
جونز وفازت بمنصب حاكم الولايه التي يغلب
عليها الحزب الجمهوري ويحتفظ فيها الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب بشعبيه
كبيره وكانت استطلاعات الراي يرجحت فوزيه
ساندريزا البالغه من العمر 40 عاما في هذه
الولايه حيث كان والدها مايك هوبا الشخصيه
المهمه في السياسه الامريكيه حاكما من عام
1996 الى العام 2007
فازت النشطه والمحاميه الديمقراطيه كاتي
هوشول لبي منصب حاكم ولايه نيويورك على
منافسها الجمهوريه ليزلدن المدعوم من
ترامب فوزي ان يجعلها اول امراه منتخب
لهذا المنصب الذي تولته في العام 2021 عقب
استقاله الحاكم السابق اندرو كومو علما
بان فوزها كان متوقعا في ولايه يبلغ عدد
الديمقراطيين المسجلين فيها اكثر من ضعف
الجمهوريين
الله وبركاته
الكامله ويعيشون في مجتمعات دون خوف
التمتع بالاماني للتجول في الشوارع وركوب
قطارات الانفاق دون تواجد الاسلحه غير
القانونيه وسيصبح مكانا تتم فيه حمايه
الحقوق الاساسيه ويمكن للنساء
بشان اجسادهم
الذي يعترينا هنا اليوم قد تحطم اخيرا في
ولايه نيويورك
[تصفيق]
فاذا سنه الجمهوريه تشاد جروسلي بمقعد
مجلس الشيوخ عن ولايه ايوا في ولايه
الثامنه له وتعد المنافسه هي الاخيره
لسيناتور لجمهوريه البالغ من العمر 89
عاما في مواجهه الديمقراطي والعسكري
السابق مايكل فرانكن في مواجهه هي الاكثر
حد لهم منذ نحو 40 عاما وشغل براسلي منصب
الرئيس المؤقت لمجلس الشيوخ بين عامي 2019
و20121 كما ركزت حملته الانتخابيه هذا
العام على ازمه التضخم في الولايات
المتحده في ظل دعم من الرئيس الامريكي
السابق
هذه التغطيه مستمره وفيها ايضا بعد الفاصل
سواء فازوا او خسر الجمهوريون سيغيرونه
زعيمهم في مجلس الشيوخ الذي لا يحب ترامب
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله مع اقترابي اعلان نتائج
الانتخابات النصفيه وتزايد توقعات سيطره
الجمهوريين على مجلس النواب تواجه اداره
الرئيس بايدن تحديات كبيره من حزب تواعد
بعرقله اعمالها والتحقيق في افعالها
قد لا تنجو الاداره الحاليه من تهديد
الرقابه والاصلاح الذي توعد به الجمهوريون
خاصه في ملف اوكرانيا اذا جاءت نتائج
الانتخابات النصفيه لصالح الحزب الجمهوري
في الحزب الذي يحظى باغلبيه مقاعد
الكونجرس يسيطر على رئاسه اللجان المختصه
فيه التي عاده ما تعقد للتحقيق والمحاسبه
مكارتي الذي من المتوقع ان يصبح رئيسا
لمجلس النواب توعد بعقد جلسات استماع عن
قضيه الجارحه والمهاجرين غير القانونيين
والانسحاب من افغانستان وتحقيق وزاره
العدل مع الرئيس السابق
المحاسبه قد تطال رئيسا في النائبه ماجيري
جرين تواعدت بالسعي لعزل بيضه وطرحت 14
مشروعا لذلك على توهم الانسحاب الفوضوي
وتعريض حدود البلاد للخطر على الاغلب
سيفتح الجمهوريون ملفات تركز على السياح
الامريكيين من الوضع الاقتصادي كما فعله
في حملاتهم الانتخابيه لكن هذه الملفات لن
تفتح قبل بدايه العام المقبل وذلك لحين
تسلم وجوه الكونغرس الجديده مقاعدها
يوتيوب يوتيوب
[موسيقى]
اسئله التعامل
وين وين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بك يا دكتور
اولا انا اعتقد ان الموجه الحمراء التي
كان يتوقعها الكثيرون لم تحلف بدون شك
حققه الجمهوريون انتصارات في عدد من
الولايات المهمه ولكنهم لم يستطيعوا تحقيق
الانتصارات التي كانوا يتوقعونها في بعض
الولايات الاخرى ولا تزال هناك اسئله الان
حول على الاقل اربع مقاعد في مجلس الشيوخ
التي ستقرر من سيطره على هذا المسجد
وبالتالي فان هذه
تظهر بانه لا يزال هناك انقسام حاده داخل
المجتمع الامريكي وهذا الانقسام هو انقسام
عمودي وعلى الرغم من همم ان التوقع وبعض
السطات رايت تظهر بان الجمهوريين همم قد
يتقدموا كثيرا ست هناك هذه الموجه ولكن
يبدو انها لم تحدث حتى الان ولكن الان
فرصه الحقيقيه هي الان لا تزال امام
الجمهوريين في السيطره على مجلس النواب
واذا فعلوا ذلك فان هذا سيعني بان همم هذا
هذا الانتصار وهذا الفوز اذا تحقق يعني
بانه سيشل ايدي الرئيس بايرن فيما يتعلق
بعد عدد من القضايا الداخليه والخارجيه
كما انها ستفتح الباب بالنسبه امام
الجمهوريه
لتفتح تحقيقات كما ذكرتهم في تقريركم
بالنسبه لاعاده من القضايا الرئيسيه التي
ستزعج الديمقراطيين وتفرقهم خاصه الموضوع
انترنت والاموال التي حصل عليها ان كان
ذلك من اوكرانيا او روسيا او الصين او غير
ذلك بالاضافه الى اداء الرئيس وقدرته على
القيام بمهامه بالاضافه الى كل ذلك هناك
همم طبعا همم تحقيقات تتعلق بالطريقه التي
تعاملت بها همم وزاره العدل عن الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب وانصاره همم هذا يعني
بان الصراع سيستمر ولكن اذا كان
الديمقراطيون لا يزال يسيطروا على مجلس
الشيوخ طبعا هذه ستعني ان المعركه المعارك
ستستمر ولكن هناك انقسام حاد ولم نرى
تغييرات جبريه همم في المواقف وفي همم
النتائج بالاحرار همم ولذلك اعتقد ان هذه
همم المعركه اليوم فعلا سيكون مهما جدا
فيما يتعلق بنتائج مجلس الشيوخ ومجلس
النواب لان الجمهوريين ايضا على الرغم من
انهم يتقدموا في مجلس همم النواب لان
الارقام غير كافيه حتى الان ليسيطر على
المجلس ولذلك يج بغار النتائج ولكن
التوقعات لا تزال همم هي بانهم ربما
فراسهم افضل من فرص الديمقراطيين ولكن
الكثير سيعتمد على فرز الاصوات لانه وفي
بعض الولايات سنرى همم ان الاصوات ستكون
متقاربه لدرجه مثلا في ولايه جورجيا وهذا
اذا كانت قريبه جدا فان هذا يعني اعاده
التصوير طيب دكتور يعني اذا اذا ما حتى
الان لم يحدث او لم يحدث تلك المفاجاه هل
سيستمر الجمهوريون بتشكيل صداع للرئيس
حتى ان لم يكن لديهم الاغلبيه اما ان ذلك
همم من عدم حسمهم لهذه الانتخابات سيجعل
ترامب في موقف المتردد على الاقل من لا
يعلن ترشحه للانتخابات الرئاسيه القادمه
وقد يكون هناك بديل داخل الحزب الجمهوري
حكم فلوريدا مثلا
انتصار الجمهوريه
لعب الرئيس السابق ترامب دور مهم في ذلك
وكذلك حاكم الولايه
ولكن هناك ايضا توتر
ترامب لان ديسانتس همم يعمل في ان يرشح
نفسه وعلى الاقل هذا ما يعتقد للرئاسه
بينما بدا الرئيس ترامب يحذر منافسيه ومن
بينهم
بان لا يدخلوا هذه المعنى وبالتالي فانا
اذا تم هذا الصراع اذا راينا مثلا
قرر ترشيح نفسه للرئاسه فان هذا يعني
خلافات داخل الحزب الجمهوري
بهذا سيضع الحزب ولكن اذا استطاع الرئيس
ترامب وهو حتى الان يبدو انه الاقوى داخل
الحزب الجمهوري حيث ان غاليه على قل على
مستوى القاعده وهمم ان لم يكن على مستوى
القيادات الجمهوريه وخاصه في مجلس الشيوخ
فان فرص همم الرئيس ترامب هي افضل بكثير
من دي سانتوس ولكن اذا بدانا نرى ان عدد
من
الجمهوريين يتسائل خاصه انهم لم يحققوا
الانتصار الذي كانوا يعمل بتحقيقه فان
البعض منهم سيبدا بتوجيه اللوم الى الرئيس
ترامب الى دائره ويقول هؤلاء انه لولا همم
تصرفات الرئيس ترامب كان الجمهوريين في
وضع افضل همم وبالتالي هذا يعكس هذا
الانقسام الذي قد نراه بين الرئيس ترامب
وبعض الجمهوريين حيث انه دعم مؤخرا ايضا
تغيير القياده الجمهوريه في مجلس الشيوخ
هذه السنه المقانه الذي توجد خلافات كبيره
بينه وبين الرئيس ترامب ولذلك اعتقد ان
الجمهوريين ايضا سيواجه تحديات كبيره وليس
فقط الديمقراطيين ولكن هناك ايضا قضايا
اخرى تتعلق مثلا للسياسه الخارجيه والحربي
اوكرانيا
عدد من الاسواق عدد همم
تقلص الدعم
همم لاوكرانيا حيث ان انا مثلا ال- ال-
الكوبيين وهم من اقوى المنظمات التنظيمات
همم في الولايات المتحده اليمنيه
والمعاديه اليسار المعاديه للشيوعيه هؤلاء
كانوا يتمنوا اي مواقف معاديه لليسار
ولكنهم الان بدانا كما راينا في ولايه
الورد وفي الولايات اخرى بداوا يطالبوا
بوقف الدعم او تقليص الدعم لي اوكرانيا
ويقولوا ان علينا التركيز على الوضع
الداخلي ان الدافع الضرائب الامريكي يجب
ان يركز على القضايا الداخليه ان يحمل
حدود الجنوبيه وليس ح- اا حلول اوكرانيا
وهذه نقطه مثيره لان هؤلاء كانوا كما قلت
همم هم من اقوى المعادين لليسار وهناك
اصوات متزايده حتى في اوساط المستقلين
وبعض الديمقراطيين الذين يعرضوا انفاق
الاموال الكبيره ويعتقد ان السياسه التي
يتبناها سبايدر تدفع روسيا والصين الى
احضان بعضهم البعض وهذا يعزز البلل قوه
البلدين ويضعف قوه الولايات المتحده شكرا
جزيلا يا دكتور عدنان غريبه الاستاذ في
العلاقه الدوليه كنت معنا من واشنطن شكرا
جزيلا لك
قلها اسئله الجمهوريه عن ولايه ميزوريه
انه لن يدعم السيناتور ماتش ماكوينويل
لولايه
مكونه من عفوا لولايه اخرى زعيم
للجمهوريين في مجلس الشيوخ وقله ان على
الجمهوريين اختيار زعيم جديد يعبر عن رؤيه
الحزب في حين انا
ابتعد عن هذه السياسه بموافقته على مشروع
تمويل الدفاع اوكرانيا ويواجه ماكونال
هجوما من الجمهوريين اضافه الى انه في
عداوه مباشره مع الرئيس السابق
اذا كما ذكرنا فازات ديمقراطيه جون فترمان
بمقعد في ولايه بنسلفانيا ذات الاهميه
الكبيره في الانتخابات النصفيه واجهه
فترمان الذي كان يتعافى من جلطه اندماغيه
اصيب بها في مايو المرشح الجمهوري محمد
اوز في واحده من اكثر المعارك تنافسيه في
انتخابات منتصف الولايه وقال فتر من في
مؤتمر صحفي اراهن على سكان بنسلفانيا ولم
يخدموننا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
لما اتوقع ابدا اننا سنحول هذه المقاطعه
الحمراء الى اللون الازرق لكننا فعلنا ما
احتجنا الى القيم به واجرينا تلك النقاشات
عبر كل واحده من تلك المقاطعه والليله
ساكون سيناتور القادم من بنسلفانيا فخور
جدا بالسباق
على سكان بنسلفانيا ولم يخدمونا لن اخذ
لكم بتاتا
هذه الساعه انتهت لكن تغطياتنا للانتخابات
النصفيه الامريكيه مستمره في ساعاتنا
الاخباريه تفاصيل الصوره دائما مع العربيه
وان تعرفوا اكثر قمعنا اذا في امان الكريم
[موسيقى]